>> Yeah, in terms of the question will China
us pull out of the
economy's critical crisis -- I don't think
China can take too much
heavy responsibility at this time.
China, in past three decades, even China has
already achieved very
great accomplishment in economic growth but
mostly depends too heavy on
low, low-end or cheap labor in terms of business.
So I think China also need more time to enhance
or increase its
capability in knowledge-base industry and
also increase R&D capability.
So, but anyhow, China is also a very huge
market, consumer market, so I
think definitely China will keep the world
-- more contribute in
economy, advice, huge consumer market.
But also China needs some time to increase
or enhance this
knowledge-intensive capability is my point.